hi grammarians today i want to talk
about this idea in english that we call
agreement so i'm going to teach you how
to be agreeable and make it so that all
of your sentences get along really well
let me let me give you an example the
dog
barks
as opposed to
the dogs
bark
do you see the difference
it's funny because the s
seems to
seems to migrate
seems to move from one part of the
sentence to the other
so what you wouldn't say is
the dog
bark
that doesn't work
and you wouldn't say
the dogs
barks
i know that's that seems strange that
you wouldn't want to have
the s
follow the other s
but you actually only want to have
one of these
in a sentence so the dog barks the dogs
bark
when there's only one of something
strangely in the present you know in the
present tense it takes this s
so
jake
bakes a cake
we
bake
a cake
not
jake
bake
a cake
which admittedly is a fun sentence to
say but this is not in standard english
this is not correct
it doesn't it doesn't exhibit what we
call agreement
similarly you also wouldn't say
we
bakes
a cake
if you're familiar with the lord of the
rings books or movies if you remember
gollum the character gollum this is a
weird little
bug-eyed critter
who's just kind of obsessed with the one
ring
and he has this very particular way of
speaking that is not strictly speaking
standard
he's just wild about that ring
and the way he refers to everything is
he just throws on an s
uh on the end of every word he uses
every verb
so if he's talking about
you know
this this magic ring that he's very fond
of
which he calls the precious uh he
wouldn't just say
i love it he'd say i loves it
like so and that's not correct that does
not but does not show agreement so the
test here is really
you can figure out whether or not you
are using agreement in your sentences if
you sound like gollum
because if gollum were being grammatical
he would say
i love
it so this is this is the sense that i
want you to develop is you listen to
yourself speak and you ask do i sound
like gollum the ring monster
because if you do sound like gollum then
you're probably not operating under the
the agreement rules of standard american
english
or you're just doing a golem impression
that's the basic idea behind agreement
is you just want to make sure that that
the parts of the sentence match up
sentence parts
match
they agree they get along they work
you can learn anything
david out